on va parler aujourd'hui dans cette
chronique santé d'une déformation de la
colonne vertébrale qui apparaît le plus
souvent à l'adolescence et qui touche
majoritairement les filles la scoliose
peut être traitée dans la très grande
majorité des cas avec notamment le port
d'un corset de maintien jusqu'à la fin
de la croissance et pour les cas les
plus graves de nouvelles techniques de
chirurgie existe on en parle avec vous
jullet siggers bonjour julliard tout
d'abord qu'est-ce que la scoliose et
combien de personnes en souffrent alors
les scolioses c'est une déviation
sinueuses de la colonne vertébrale comme
vous l'avez dit qu'il va commencer à
prendre la forme d'un ace équivalent
veut le faire en 3d d'ailleurs ma
pouvoir le voir sur différents plans et
qui va donc commencer à tourner un peu
sur elle même comme un un escalier en
colimaçon et pour mesurer sa gravité on
va utiliser ce que l'on appelle l'embl
l'angle de cobb alors on ne comprend pas
encore aujourd'hui très bien quelles
sont les raisons de la scoliose et
contre toute attente ce ne serait pas dû
à une mauvaise posture ou encore au fait
de 2,2 de porter un sac lourd comme le
pensent par exemple de nombreux parents
plutôt on pense que les red iter est
assez important puisqu'on trouve dans
les familles et aussi on soupçonne par
exemple une perturbation de ce que l'on
appelle le système vestibulaire qui est
en charge de l' équilibre tout
simplement ou encore de la glande
pinéale que l'on trouve donc dans le
cerveau et qui sécrètent de la
mélatonine alors vous avez environ 2 à 4
% des enfants aujourd'hui qui seront
concernés par la scoliose et de ses 2 à
4 % 80 à 90% sont des filles donc on
sait aujourd'hui que le sexe est un
facteur risque très important même si on
ne sais pas l'expliquer aujourd'hui
alors certains enfants vont avoir des
scolioses
assez légères d'autres beaucoup plus
sévères et c'est un mal en fait qui
avance masqué sans douleur ni symptômes
pendant de nombreuses années c'est pour
ça que c'est important de le
diagnostiquer très tôt en tout cas c'est
la meilleure le meilleur moyen pour
essayer de stopper sa progression alors
comment la détecter julien alors eh bien
tout simplement il existe un test très
simple que les parents peuvent faire
chez eux à peu près tous les 6 mois vous
allez lui demander à votre enfant ou à
votre ado de se pencher vers l'avant
avec les jambes tendus et serrés et de
mettre en fait les deux mains entre les
genoux c'est ce que l'on appelle le test
d'adam vous allez vous positionner
derrière votre enfant et en regardant
son dos vous allez peut-être et voir une
asymétrie coastal c'est à dire que et
bien son dos ne va être un peu pencher
d'un côté ou alors vous allez peut-être
voir une lucarne si vous le regardez de
dos quand il est droit et bien vous
allez voir une lucarne sur le côté de
son corps et bien si vous voyez ces deux
signes différents et bien il faut
prendre rendez vous avec un pédiatre
pour faire une analyse un petit peu plus
poussée et comment traiter le problème
alors tout dépend évidemment de l'ua du
degré de courbure de l'enfant ou de
l'adolescent alors soit c'est une
courbure qui est assez faible auquel cas
il faudra peut-être juste le suivre si
c'est un peu plus sévère on va plutôt
proposer le de mettre ce que l'on
appelle un corset alors aujourd'hui ses
corsets s'enfilent comme des t-shirts
ils sont thermoformé ils sont beaucoup
plus agréables que ce qu'on a pu voir
par le passé est par contre si c'est
plus sévère est bien là il faudra peut
être passer par le bloc opératoire pour
justement faire une chirurgie alors là
l'opération traditionnel de la scoliose
c'est ce que l'on appelle l' art rodez
vertébrale donc là ce qu'on va faire
c'est qu'on va implanter en fait
dévisser des crochets dans les vertèbres
que l'on va connecter avec des grandes
tiges et on va fusionner en fait elle
les vertèbres souvent dans le bas du dos
le problème c'est que c'est une
opération est évidemment très invasive
et surtout on perd de la mobilité au
niveau de la colonne vertébrale et il
existe aujourd'hui une nouvelle pratique
chirurgicale qui permet en fait de
traiter les scolioses sévère et qui
vient cette fois-ci
rectifié en fait la colonne vertébrale à
l'intérieur c'est une technique qui nous
vient des états unis et qui pratiquaient
déjà depuis quelques années par le
professeur aurélien courvoisier cette
technique s'appelle la modulation de
croissance vertébrale on les écoute il
nous explique comment fonctionne cette
technique à ce que les onze c'est une
déformation progressive de la colonne
vertébrale au fur et à mesure de la
croissance et qu'est ce qui se passe en
réalité en réalité normalement
voilà ça c'est trois vertèbres vue de
face normalement grandi de la même
manière du côté droit et du côté gauche
si bien quitter la table sont
symétriques canton quand on a une
scoliose et que et que le processus
avance dont la croissance finalement
qu'est ce qui se passe parce que le l'un
des côtés alors souvent c'est côté droit
pour les zones pour la zone thoracique
le le côté droit grandi plus vite que le
côté gauche
et qu'est ce qui se passe et on voit
bien que les vertèbres au lieu d'être
rectangulaire ça c'est très schématique
mais c'est à peu près comme ça que ça se
passe elles deviennent trapézoïdale
c'est à dire que le côté concave et plus
petits mots que le côté complexe alors
qu'est ce qui se passe dans cette triste
ont bien faire c'est combien placé davis
haut niveau la convexité des vertèbres
et ont bien placé un call un câble qui
ressemble finalement un gros lacets de
chaussures de randonnée très costaud on
vient tendre le câble on tire dessus si
bien que de la même manière qu'avec le
corse et externe mais de manière
beaucoup plus puissante on vient
corriger la colonne vertébrale
alors vous comprenez dans les
explications du professeur qu'on voyait
qu'eux en fait ce qui est extraordinaire
avec cette technique c'est qu'on va
venir changer la forme même de la
vertèbre donc avec ce fils que l'on va
attendre du côté qui a grandi plus vite
on va stopper la croissance et on va
permettre de réajuster la colonne et vu
que l'enfant va continuer à grandir et
bien le côté gauche va continuer à
grandir et ça va redevenir en fait un
rectangle alors que si l'on met qu'un
corset et bien la vertèbre continue à
avoir cette forme trappe de trapèze en
fait donc là on vient vraiment changer
la forme il faut dire évidemment que ça
ne fonctionne pas pour tous tous les
types de scoliose il faut que la
courbure soit sévère mais qu'elles
soient souples malgré tout ce qui n'est
pas toujours le cas il faut aussi que la
croissance ne soit pas terminée parce
qu'on utilise justement la croissance de
l'enfant pour pour rectifier donc sa
colonne vertébrale et c'est vrai que
c'est une
chirurgie qui est moins invasive
également et surtout eh bien on garde
justement de la flexibilité dans la
colonne vertébrale et enfin ce qui est
important aussi c'est de ne pas le faire
on sait que dans certains cas il faut
pas le faire trop tôt non plus pour
parfaire une hyper correction à l
inverse et si cette chirurgie ne marche
pas et bien on peut revenir vers la
chirurgie plus traditionnelles de leur
trop days merci beaucoup julia pour
votre chronique santé